the cowl of justice is always watching
it's Batman
[Music]
it's Double Trouble went to face and mr.
freeze steal a crate of chemicals from
Gotham Harbor
but these nefarious fiends are in for
the darkest night of their life this
dark night it's black man to face turns
up the sass and releases the gas with
this tommy gun fat man takes them both
down with all 24 points of articulation
it's Batman and he's back because he
never left where did he go nowhere it's
Batman
oh no time to ice and dice but look it's
Catwoman with a cool necklace the cat
whips the sad old man with spider legs
into shape I still Avista frizzy this
Kitty's got claws and a cat how about a
kiss Batman how about a high five Batman
and Catwoman high-five each other for a
job well done
they're never gonna kiss how come you
always get to play Batman because I am
Batman
no you're not yeah you're right I'm not
hey you want to make them kiss now yeah
count of three one two three guys do you
still need the conference room five more
minutes DC collectibles Batman animated
action figures blocks epic ducks fo Dini
Kevin Smith booming narrator voice and
hand models not included it's Batman and
coming soon it's the Batmobile
[Music]